et la poupée a-t-elle été éliminée
affirmatifs
dans les rouges je lui souhaite bonne
chance salut c'est Alex je me demandais
si tu avais bien reçu mes messages
[Musique]
c'est vraiment super chaud d'être passé
me voir vous êtes en couple non oui mais
on sait pas parler de la semaine la meuf
mais en fait ça tombe malade
on se revoit un autre jour d'accord
le Mania du jouet Philippe pepperwindt
va être libéré suite à la disparition de
certaines pièces à conviction
il y a un truc qui va pas alex je le
sens tu trouves pas qu'il ressemble à
l'autre on dirait le même je ressemble à
rien il faut vraiment être pas bien dans
sa tête pour acheter un tissu pareil ta
mère elle bosse pour le Père Noël ou
quoi c'est un grand jour pour moi il
faudra qu'on soit là quand il sortira
qu'est-ce que c'est que la cieux et
quelle magnifique
tu connais ça un Ron
à ta liberté je tends l'oreille toi tu
ouvres l'oeil là maintenant ce que je
veux c'est m'occuper de ces gamins
tu veux devenir un ninja ou pas mais je
te jure que je vais le découvrir
[Musique]
ton téléphone sonne tu es un ami minable
et toi tu es un ninja minable vous êtes
grillé c'est grill
[Musique]
vous pouvez mettre de la crème dans le
dos et après je vous en mettrai partout
ça vous dit
[Musique]